The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: All
right, let's get going.
So today, I'll say a few
more words about PDEs,
and then we'll leave
that topic for a while.
I think I'll actually
come back and have
a little lecture about that
right before Thanksgiving,
for those of you still around.
And then we'll start
talking about probability,
and then that will lead
into several lectures
about models versus data,
which is a very important topic
for all of you who either
plan to generate data
or plan to generate models
during your stay here,
which probably is everybody.
So we'll talk about
that for a while.
So PDEs.
I guess the first comment is,
homework 7, have any of you
looked at this yet?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
Not a single one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: So
homework 7 is the same problem
that Kristin showed in class
in the demo for COMSOL,
and I want you to
solve it both ways.
So solve it with
COMSOL and then solve
it writing your own
finite volume code.
And I want to warn you.
This problem has a
characteristic length
that's way smaller than the
dimensions of the problem.
And so in principle,
you might need
to use an incredibly
fine mesh to resolve
the gradients in the problem.
So just remember, in case
you haven't looked at it,
the problem is we
have a drug patch.
It has some concentration
of the drug.
The drug is diffusing slowly
out of the patch into the flow,
and we have some
flow here like that.
And the characteristic
length is at the--
this is a velocity
boundary layer.
So the velocity
in the x-direction
is equal to y times
something, dv dy, I guess.
This is some number, and
so this has units of--
what is that-- per second,
so like a strain rate, OK?
And the diffusion here is
controlled by diffusivity D,
and that has units of, say,
centimeter squared per second.
And so the D over
dvx dy, this thing
gives a characteristic
length squared,
which is sort of the natural
length scale of this problem.
And the problem is that
for the drug molecule,
it's a big molecule.
It has a very small diffusivity.
And so therefore, this
is a really tiny ratio,
and so the L is very small.
And similarly, if you
look at it from the point
of view in the x-direction,
the Peclet number
is really gigantic.
And so both of those will tell
you that you have to watch out,
there might be very sharp
gradients in the problem.
And if you just think of it
physically, right over here
we think the concentration's
0, somewhere over here.
And all of a sudden right
here, the concentration
is going to be close to the
concentration in the patch.
So there's almost
a discontinuity
in the concentration.
So there's a really sharp
gradient on the upstream edge.
And then something funky is
going to happen down here
at the end of the patch, too.
It won't be quite as abrupt,
but could be pretty strange.
All right, so you got it?
OK.
And in the problem, we
want you to figure out
the drug diffusing all the
way over to here somewhere,
way far over there.
And so you may need quite a few
mesh points in the y-direction
as well.
All right.
And this kind of problem, this
is a very simple case, right?
There's no reactions.
The velocity's just
in one direction,
and this is not
a very hard case.
But you'll see
it's actually still
pretty tricky to get
the right solution.
So don't just believe
what the code tells you.
Just run COMSOL and just--
don't believe it's
showing the truth.
And don't believe you just
write down some finite volumes
that you'll get the truth.
So mess around with it and
try to convince yourself
it's really converged,
and you really
have the real physical solution.
Because we expect
a sharp gradient,
say, in the upstream
edge, you might
want to play with using a
finer mesh in the x-direction
here than you would down here,
because down here presumably
the gradients in x-direction
are much smaller.
So you don't have to use
square finite volumes.
You could use rectangles.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't
understand what
you have written [INAUDIBLE]
as vx equal y dvx dy.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what--
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: So that's
because the velocity-- the vx
is 0 at the wall, and the
velocity increases with y.
So vx increases the
further you get from y.
This is y equals 0,
always going up that way.
As you can increase the
height, the flow gets faster.
And that's typical, because
you have a no-slip boundary
condition at the wall, right?
Is that OK, or did I
misunderstand your question?
Is that good?
OK?
AUDIENCE: So y is a constant.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yeah,
in this particular problem
this is just a number that
we tell you in the problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Right.
If you had a flow in
a cylindrical pipe,
it wouldn't be--
wouldn't be a number.
Be more complicated,
yeah, all right?
So this is-- I mean, again, this
is like the simplest you got.
It's only 2D.
It's really simple.
But you're going to see
here that even here you
could have a lot of trouble.
And if you just don't
think about it--
the computer will
give you an answer.
Whatever-- you put in some
finite difference equations
or finite element
equations, finite volume
equations, fsolve,
whatever, it's
going to solve and
give you some numbers.
It doesn't mean it
has any relation
to the physical reality.
So this is a problem
to really pay attention
to whether you're
really converged.
All right.
And so what I suggest you
do in this problem is go
through a sequence
where you vary--
the real problem wants you to do
this all the way out to-- this
is 1 centimeter.
But I suggest you instead
solve a simpler problem,
where you put the--
here's a simpler problem.
Put your boundary right
here, really close, and then
solve that problem.
You won't need as many
mesh points across
to get from here to here.
And this should be--
this is-- suppose
you choose this
is c equal 0 boundary
condition for this wall,
then this should
be an upper bound.
Because if you put an
absorbing layer here,
it should drive the
diffusion faster, right?
So as you increase
this distance--
let's call it little h--
as you increase
little h, you should
converge to the true
solution that you
want sort of from above.
Does that makes sense?
Yeah?
Is this OK?
All right.
And similarly, you
can vary the mesh,
how big your boxes are,
say, in delta x and delta y.
And again, for
each of those, you
could think about how
should things converge.
And so look and see
if it's actually
converging the way you think
it should be converging, right?
Any more questions about this?
OK, so this problem might--
this homework problem
might look like a
MATLAB coding problem.
It has MATLAB coding,
but it's not really--
that's not really what it is.
It's really like a--
it's a conceptual problem
about what you're doing.
All right.
All right, in this problem, I
want you to use finite volumes.
So let's talk about finite
volumes for a minute.
So finite volumes is to imagine
that we have little control
volumes, and each one of them
has a little propeller in it,
stirs it up, like little CSTRs.
And so we do it just like you
did back in your intro ChemE
class and mass/energy
balances a million years ago.
You know that you have
some flow coming in here,
and maybe some flow
going out there.
And maybe you have
some flux come in here
and maybe something out there.
And you can add up all the
flows in and all the flows out,
and then that--
the net of all
these fluxes has got
to be equal to the accumulation.
And if we're doing a
steady-state problem,
then there's no time derivative,
so the accumulation term
should be 0.
And you did a lot
of these problems
a long time ago, right?
OK, so you just do it like that.
The only problem is now we have
a million of these little boxes
all coupled to each other.
So you get one
equation for each box.
And in this problem,
we're going to--
when you do this method,
what people assume
is that you have a
uniform concentration
sort of across
here or the number
you use as the average of
the concentration in the cell
as [INAUDIBLE].
And so it's not really
exactly realistic.
So that's where the
approximation is.
What you're doing
at the boundaries
is very realistic, because
you're actually computing
the fluxes across
control volumes
is exactly the way
you should do it.
So there's different methods,
right, finite element,
finite difference,
finite volume.
The nice thing
about finite volume
is you're really
treating exactly what's
happening across the boundaries
of the mesh area, the mesh
volume.
And we'll find that a lot
of ChemE problems, this
is how people prefer to do it.
And because you're treating
the fluxes exactly,
if you have your mesh
volume sitting on the wall
or on top of the
drug patch, suppose
if we're sitting right on
top of the drug patch here.
Then if you're sitting--
first, let's do a wall.
Suppose you're sitting
on an impermeable wall,
then we just know that the flux
here will be 0 if it's a wall.
So that's easy.
No flux here.
So we only have to worry
about this one, this one,
and this one.
That one's not doing anything.
This case, if you say in the
drug patch there is a flux,
stuff's coming in
and you'll need
to figure out how to write
that boundary condition.
So the boundary condition as
written is that C, the drug,
is equal to some number, C
drug, whatever is in the patch.
But that's not so
easy to impose here.
And so there's two
ways to look at it.
One way is people compute
this flux by considering--
suppose I know this
is C drug here.
I'm trying to really
figure out what's
the average concentration here.
And so one way to
compute this is
to say it's the diffusivity
times C drug minus C
the middle over delta y over 2.
That would be the flux.
So that's one way to look at it.
Another way people
look at it is they draw
what they call a ghost volume.
And so here, here's my C
that I care about, C middle.
Here's C ghost.
And here is the
line between them.
Now, I can use the
same equation here
that they would
have used before.
But I don't know what C
ghost is, because there's
no real cell here.
This is below the patch.
Here's the patch.
But imagine the patch is
not there for a second,
and I write down the same
equation I would have here.
And the flux diffusively would
have been D C ghost minus C
middle over delta y.
That's what you would have
written as the diffusive flux.
And I don't know
what C ghost is.
So now, I have to
think about how
do I estimate what C ghost is.
I can say, well, let's
do a linear interpolation
from this concentration
to that concentration.
So let's say that the C
boundary is equal to C
ghost, the average of these
two, plus C mid over 2.
That's what we got if we
did a linear interpolation
between these two guys to
figure out what it is here.
But here we know what it is.
We know what a C boundary is.
That's the concentration
of the drug patch
so that we can solve
for what c ghost is.
AUDIENCE: How do you
know what C middle is?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: C
middle is the unknown.
That's what we're
going to compute.
We just want an equation that
involves C middle, because we
have c middle as an unknown.
We need an equation
the involves C middle,
just like we would for--
if we have a--
If we have finite volume that
is in the interior somewhere,
we have c of this
grid point, Cij.
We just want equations
that involve Cij.
But we need an equation
that somehow connects it
to the boundary conditions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When would you
use that second [INAUDIBLE]
if you know C
boundary [INAUDIBLE]??
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Right.
And actually, I think if you
do it this way, in this case,
you get the same formula.
You're running out of C.
AUDIENCE: So when would
you use the C ghost?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
The C ghost thing is
handy when these conditions--
actually, in the finite
volumes, this is it.
I don't think you need to do it.
Maybe if you had a flow,
velocity flow here.
I don't know.
But you won't in a wall.
So I don't know if, in the
finite difference method,
you can use those ghost points
as well to do the flux gutter
conditions.
And that's often
useful to do the ghost
thing for if you have a
symmetry-imposed flux boundary
condition.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
That's the flux.
The flux is coming
from across this wall.
And we'll have to add
that with the flux coming
this way and the
flux coming this way
and the flux coming this way
to get our total flux, which
is going to net out to 0
instead of C. Is that all right?
But the other ones, you
all know how to write them?
They're just velocity flows.
The nice thing about
the finite volume method
is that when you're trying
to consider the velocity,
the velocity that matters is
actually the velocity here.
It's the flux that couples the
two finite values together.
So your velocity is
being evaluated halfway
between the two
mesh point centers.
This turns out to make the
whole procedure more numerically
stable.
You compute the flux
by, say, the difference
between these two.
And you're implicitly evaluating
right at halfway between.
Other methods, like
finite difference,
you're trying to get
the velocity or the flux
at the same point here.
And it doesn't really
make much sense,
from the point of view of trying
to compute how much material's
close to here, to use
the velocity right there.
And so when you work out
equations, and particularly
the equations that
involve pressure,
so suppose you try to discretize
the Navier-Stokes equations
and you have a pressure gradient
that's driving the flow,
then you have to figure
out where are you
going to evaluate the pressures
and where are you going
to evaluate the velocities.
And when you try to evaluate
them at the same point,
it turns out that you get
numerically unstable problems.
But if you do it by this
funny volume method,
then it just works
out naturally.
It's fine.
And then you need
special methods,
if you're going to try
to do it where you have
the velocity of the mesh at
the same point as the pressure
mesh.
You'll notice in most of
the problems we give you,
we just leave pressure out.
We try to rewrite the equations
so no pressure ever appears.
And that's because
pressure in general
is a problem, because you can
have acoustic waves physically.
And if you do the equations,
which allow for acoustic waves,
you'll get them in the
numerical solution as well.
But usually, we don't
care about that.
So you have sound waves
racing around your solution,
and that causes a lot
of trouble numerically.
So a lot of times, people
rewrite the equations
to try to remove the
pressure from the equation.
So you write down the
Navier-Stokes equations.
You guys did this transport.
Maybe you'll study that today
in the class, in the test.
I don't know.
Anyway, there's a pressure term
if you just write naturally.
But oftentimes, you can remove
that by an equation of state,
for example.
And then you can get rid of it.
And that turns out to be better
from the numerical solution.
All right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So you said that
for this problem,
[INAUDIBLE] was very small.
So that means that these finite
volume cells [INAUDIBLE] you
have to do a lot of them.
[INAUDIBLE] gets around this
by having a variable volume.
Do we have to address
this on that lab that
have some variable volume?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
OK, so from the point
of view of writing a
code, it's a lot easier
to write it with fixed
mesh because all equations
look exactly the same.
So I suggest you start that way.
And what you do, if you use
a very small value of each,
then I think you'll be
able solve it, no problem.
You'll have enough mesh.
Then, once you
figure out how to do
that, now you might
be able to see,
OK, can my solver solve this?
And then that gets into
another question, actually.
What solver are
you going to use?
So any ideas about this problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: So you could
use fsolve But I'm telling you,
you're going to have to
use a lot of mesh points.
That means that fsolve's
going to have to solve
for a lot of variables.
AUDIENCE:
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
Backslash it might be.
So the key thing, the nice
thing about this problem
is it's a linear
differential equation.
There's no nonlinear term today.
So when you rewrite
the equations
of the finite volumes,
it's all going
to be linear in the unknowns.
And what else is nice about
this problem, when you use
local finite volumes as your--
It's going to be super-sparse.
So the matrix that comes in
is going to be really sparse.
And so you'll want to use
some method that can handle
gigantic sparse matrices.
So you wrote a code
like that earlier,
so that would be
one possibility.
If you know how to use
the right flags in MATLAB
to help their built-in
solvers handle sparsity,
then that should be good.
If you just ask it to
solve it by dense method,
by, like, LEU or
something, you're
going to have lot
trouble, once you've
put your mesh points in there.
But you can just experiment.
Try bigger and bigger matrices.
And then at some point,
if you have backslash,
it will give you a warning or
something, unless you tell it
that you're sparse.
All right?
Any more questions
that about this?
How would people solve it
do you think professionally?
Suppose I was doing a problem
like this in 3D instead of 2D.
How would people solve it?
What solver would they use?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Not fsolve.
No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] gradient.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yeah, so they
would use conjugate gradient.
So probably-- I think it's
called this, BiCGSTAB.
That's the program
that we would use
if you have a really, really
gigantic sparse matrix.
So that's the
conjugate gradient.
And Professor Swan talked
about, the advantage
of that is you never
have to actually store
the whole matrix.
You only need to evaluate
the matrix elements,
and then you can
throw them away.
And so if you have a
very sparse matrix,
that's pretty cheap to do.
So it's a really good code.
I think in this 2D
problem, you can probably
get away with other solvers.
You don't have to use this.
But this is a
definite possibility.
This is a built-in
MATLAB program as well.
Be warned, though, this
is an iterative solver.
It's not just going
to be one solve, boom.
And It might have troubles.
So you might want to go with
the other ones, but anyway.
May I ask you a question?
How about, do you
need initial guess?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Depends.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
Depends on the solver.
So if you solve
it with backslash,
do you need an initial guess?
If you can solve it with fsolve,
do you have to initial guess?
If you can solve
it via BiCGSTAB,
do you have to
use initial guess?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yes.
OK.
So then you have to think
about how you really
get your initial guess, too.
So this is things
to think about.
All right.
What else to tell you about?
One last thing about
PDEs, and we'll
come back to this later, so
far we haven't done really
anything that's
very time-dependent.
But a lot of real world PDEs
have a time dependent in them.
And there's is a very
important concept,
a thing called the CFL number.
And this is named
after a 1928 paper,
and I'll write the
guys' names down.
And what they showed
was that, if you're
trying to solve the
PDE system, where
you're discretizing
in both x and time,
that you have a number
that they defined
as delta t times the
velocity and the extraction
divided by delta x.
So that's a
dimensionless number.
So that's a CFL number.
You see a lot of
papers that will
say what CFL number they used.
What that means is the ratio
of their time mesh compared
to their space mesh.
And conceptually, let's think
about what's happening here.
So suppose we have
a flow flowing
in an upwards direction,
and we have a bunch
of little finite volumes.
So we've discretized
the delta x already.
And this is x.
And there's a flow here.
And I've already
decided, somehow,
what length scale I want to use.
So I've decided my delta x.
And now, I'm trying to figure
out what delta t I should use.
Now, from the point of
view of saving CPU time
I want the delta to be
as giant as possible,
because I want to be able
to zoom along or predict
for long periods of time what's
going to happen in my system.
But if I make delta
t really large,
let's think about what happens.
Suppose I choose delta t to be
10 times delta x divided by u.
So it means that in
my one time step,
I have some guess or
some current value
of the concentrations in
all these finite values.
And then I wait through
a time step that's
10 times delta x over ux.
So I had some stuff
that was here.
Where is that going
to be 10 times later?
10 time steps later.
10 blocks up, right?
So it's going to be, like,
way up here somewhere.
And so what's going
to happen there
is that my numerical methods
are all computing stuff locally
from the spatial derivatives.
But it's crazy if,
between my time steps,
this stuff completely
left the picture.
It's already convected all
the way off the screen.
And some new stuff, which
was way down here before,
is now the stuff that's here.
Should be there
if I was physical.
Numerically, who knows what will
happen if you try to do this.
But it won't be good.
So the condition
is that you need
this number to be less than
1, or same order of magnitude
as 1, and you try to make
this much bigger than 1,
then you're doing something
crazy because you're
convecting stuff over
multiple mesh points.
And so that turns out to be a
very serious limitation if you
try to do simulations
for, let's say,
a reacting flow for a
long period of time,
because you might have to
use a really tiny delta t.
And then people have developed
all different fancy methods
to try to get around that.
But if you just do the
obvious things to do,
you'll always run
into this limitation.
Then you need to choose
the time steps small.
And also, it's bad, because as
you make delta x smaller, which
improves your accuracy,
You'll have to make
your delta t's smaller, too.
But of course, making delta x
smaller increases your CPU time
because you have more
finite volumes to compute.
And then you'll also have to
make double t smaller, which
means you'll have to do
more time steps, too.
So it's even like
a double whammy.
So getting more accuracy is
going to really cost you badly.
And so this another reason
why people used to always
refer to color fluid dynamics.
You can make a pretty
picture, but it might not
be physical at all.
Because you can make it
solve equations that maybe,
for example, didn't
impose this, then
who knows what kind of
crazy stuff you'll get.
You'll got something.
It'll compute something,
but it may have no relation
to the real problem.
I think that's all I
was say about PDEs.
Are there any questions
about PDEs before I start
talking about probability?
You got it totally down.
I'm looking forward to some
really awesome solutions.
How about that?
Just one last comment.
If you decide you wanted
to do adaptive meshing
and you want to
change your mesh size,
you can choose measures
like this if you want.
And you can even do
things like this,
where you have a
bigger mesh, and then
maybe have two smaller
meshes underneath it
in the next trial.
So you can just have
stuff flowing here,
stuff flowing here
stuff flowing there.
So you can do all kinds
of crazy stuff like.
This can really help improve the
accuracy of the solution a lot.
But it's, I would say,
very prone to bugs.
So if you do this,
be really careful
and don't do it too
often, I would say.
You might have a
few boundaries where
you do something funky like
that to change that mesh size.
But don't go crazy with it.
[INAUDIBLE] is smart.
It has a really nice way of
doing the meshing for you.
So that's its advantage, that
somebody very carefully coded
how to handle this kind of
stuff in a general case.
But if you guys are doing
it for the first time,
it might not be so good.
So that's enough of PDEs.
Let's talk about probability.
So probability is everywhere,
except in undergraduate ChemE
homework problems.
So when you do problems
as an undergraduate,
they always had
some nice solution.
It was 2 pi, it was 3.0.
Everything was, like,
deterministic, is definite.
The grader could go through.
Oh, no, you're off by 0.1.
It couldn't possibly be right.
That's, like, not reality.
So any time you actually
make a measurement,
you always had
measurement noise.
And if you try to
repeat a measurement,
you don't get the same
result. So that's,
like, completely different
than an undergraduate problem.
But this is the reality.
So the reality is the world is,
like, not so nice as you think.
But actually, it's
even more fundamental.
It's nothing about--
I mean, there's
one problem about how
good an experimental
those people are, and
how fancy an apparatus
you bought that can make
things exactly reproducible.
But even if you do that
perfectly, the equations we
use really don't correspond
to the real physical reality.
So we always use the
continuum equations.
You guys probably are studying
them a lot in 1040 and 1050,
especially 1050, I guess.
But those equations
are really all
derived from averages
over ensembles
or little finite
volumes or something
if you look at the
derivation of the equations.
And reality is that the
world is full of molecules.
And so they're all
wiggling around.
And if you look in a
little finite volume,
you look right now,
you'll see that there's
27 molecules in there.
If you look a second
later, there might be 28.
Then a little later, maybe 26.
It's always fluctuating around.
But according to our average
equations that we use,
like in the Navier-Stokes
equations, it always 27.3.
But of course, there's
not 0.3 of a molecule.
So, I mean, explicitly,
it's the average
is what we're computing,
and the reality
is fluctuating around the edges.
Same thing in thermo.
We say that such-and-such has
a certain amount of energy.
But you guys have some
[INAUDIBLE] already, yes?
So you saw that's not true?
So really, all that's
saying is that's, like,
the probability, the average.
If you've had many,
many ensembles that
were exactly the same
and you average them all,
you get some number and
that's your average energy.
But for any actual
realization, it
has some different
value of the energy.
And it's even worse than that.
That's because we have
a lot of particles.
You can even go down to,
like, the microscopic level,
where you have one molecule.
And you calculate things
about that, it turns out
you have to use the
Schrodinger equation for that.
And the Schrodinger
equation explicitly
only gives you
probability densities.
So it just tells
you the probability
the molecule might be
somewhere, the electron
might be somewhere, the
energy might be something.
But it's not actually
whether it really is.
It's just saying a
probability distribution.
And every time you do the
experiment on the molecule,
you get a different result.
Now, this is super-annoying,
but it's the way life is.
Einstein got so annoyed,
he has a famous saying,
and it's "God does
not play dice."
He was, like, just completely
annoyed at these equations.
But it's the way it is.
So the reality is that things,
all we know about, really,
are probability distributions.
In most of our
work, in our lives,
we always talk about, like,
the mean or the median.
And we're talking as
if it's a real number.
But really, it's always
some distribution.
So it's time, I guess,
you're in graduate school,
it's time to, like,
face up to this.
And that's what
we're going to talk
about for the next week or two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
This also makes
it makes you wonder
what you're doing
when you make a measurement.
So if you make a measurement,
first of all, the fact
that when you measure
something repeatedly,
you're not going to get the
same number, that's alarming.
Because I want to
say I'm 5 foot 9",
this should be pretty
common, I'm always 5 foot 9".
But actually, if you measure
me multiple times, sometimes
you'll get 5' 9 and 1/4"
Some people will get 5'
8 and 3/4" So it might make
you worry, did I change?
Did I grow between
the measurements?
So that's one issue.
Because our experiments
are not repeatable
and we get different
numbers every time
we make a measurement,
then we have a big problem.
Somebody says,
well, I really want
to know how tall
Professor Green is.
I've always wondered,
how tall is he?
And everybody's told
me a different number.
And when you go
measure it again,
you get a different
number again.
What's going on?
And so you'll have
to then-- then we
have, like, a
concept that there is
a true height of Professor
Green and we just
don't know what it is.
And then we'll try
maybe to make repeated
measurements of my height, and
then maybe take the average.
That would be the
obvious thing to do.
And we take the average
and report that.
We'll tell the boss,
we'll lie to him, say, oh,
Professor Green's 5 foot 9".
When really, we never
actually measured 5' foot 9".
Every time we measured, it was
5' 9 and 1/8", 5' 8 and 3/4".
Every time, it was
something different.
But we just say, OK, it's 5' 9".
And the boss, he doesn't want to
know about all this complexity,
anyway, so he just believes you.
So it takes your average number.
But you know that you're not
really sure I'm exactly 5' 9"
And so you have a
probability distribution,
and you're doing
your best guess.
And in fact, if you're
honest to your boss,
you'll give him an error bar.
You'll say he's 5' 9",
plus or minus 1/2 an inch.
And that way, what
you're saying is
you're pretty sure the true
height of Professor Green
is somewhere in that range.
Is this OK?
Yeah.
Now it might be that I'm
actually changing height.
I get a good night's rest,
I lie down for a long time.
Maybe when I stretch
out a little bit.
When I stand up in front of
lecture here for a long time,
I'm shrinking.
My vertebrae are
being compressed
by standing here so long.
So it's, like, a
combination of things.
One is your measurement
system is not perfect,
and one is that I actually
might be fluctuating.
I had a big breakfast,
I'm growing.
So is it true with everything?
Every experiment
you do is like this,
that there is a real fluctuation
of the real, physical apparatus
of the thing that you're trying
to measure because mostly,
things we're trying to
measure have fluctuations
intrinsically.
And then on top of that,
your measurement device
is fluctuating, which
means-- and then
the combination is
what you're measuring.
It gives you fluctuation.
If you have a very
nice instrument,
the fluctuation
of your instrument
is smaller than the
fluctuation in the real system
and you'll go down to the limit.
Anybody with a really
good instrument
should measure approximately the
same probability distribution,
which is actually
the real fluctuation.
My height, for example.
So if you bought a
laser interferometer
and mounted a mirror on my
head, and measured my height
to the wavelength
of light, you're
pretty sure that
it's pretty good.
It's within a
wavelength of light.
So the error bar there
is just due to the fact
that I slouch sometimes.
Is that OK?
So let's talk about some basic
things about probability.
So we're always saying there's
a probability of an event.
And so we want to give a number.
So for example,
I'm flipping coins.
I flip a penny, it
could be heads or tails.
I'll say the
probability of heads
is approximately equal to 1/2.
So I flipped the coin, and if
you flip the coin 100 times,
you might expect
to see 50 heads.
Now, it could be 49 heads,
it could be 51 heads.
So you have to worry about,
like, exactly how precisely you
know it.
But you think it's
something like a half.
Now, just to warn
you, I actually
didn't specify any more
significant figures here,
and it might be really
hard to figure out what
those significant figures are.
And this is related to
the measurement problem.
So we think that a coin
has about a 50/50 chance
of being heads or tails.
But if you really
wanted to prove it,
that might be really hard to do.
You can have joint
probabilities.
So suppose I have a
penny and I have a dime.
And I try to think, if I flipped
them both, what could happen?
I could have that they
both come up heads.
I could have this guy come
up heads, this guy tails.
This guy tails,
this heads, tails.
So there's, like, four
possible outcomes,
and we think they all
have about approximately
equal probabilities.
So the probability of any
of these things happening
should be about 1/4.
So you can write the probability
of event 1 and event 2.
So this would be, for
example, the probability
that I got heads for
penny and heads for dime,
and I think that
this is about 1/4.
Now, I could also say
the probability of heads,
and heads is equal to
the probability of heads
for the penny times the
probability of heads
for the dime if I got
heads for the penny.
Now, if these two coin flips
are completely uncorrelated,
then the probability of heads on
the dime and heads on the penny
is the same.
It's just the probability
of the heads on the dime.
So they don't matter.
But many things that we'll
study are correlated.
That the probability
of something happens
depends on whether
something else happened.
So this kind of expression
is very important.
Now, this is just an equality.
It's like a definition
of what these are, right?
And I'll just notice you
can write that the other way
around.
So it's the probability
of heads on the dime
times the probability
of heads on the penny.
This is OK?
So these two guys are
equal to each other,
and you can rearrange that
equation any way you want.
And we'll come back
to a very famous way
to rewrite that equation.
It's called Bayes'
theorem, and that turns out
to be really important in
model versus data comparisons.
Instead of doing AND, do OR.
So maybe you can say, then,
what's the probability
that I see at least one head?
So I flip my two coins, and
I have the probability of,
I see at least one head.
So we know we intuitively
the answer is 3/4.
But let's try to think of where
does that really come from.
So--
[HIGH-PITCHED SOUND]
What is that?
Sorry.
Really threw me there.
So probability of
at least one head,
it's not equal to the
probability of head
for the penny plus the
for the dime, because we
know this is really 3/4,
and this is 1/2, this is 1/2.
You add them up, 1/2 plus
1/2 does not equal to 3/4.
So be careful.
There's a lot of things you can
say quickly that are not true.
So anyway, you really have
to consider the whole thing.
And in the best case,
if you can enumerate
what's going to happen, it's
very simple to add up things.
Otherwise, you have to be
very careful with the algebra
to make sure you add
all things correctly.
Let's see at least what
this should be equal to.
So this should be equal
to the probability
that a head on a penny
times the probability
that I have head for the dime
if I had a head for the penny
plus probability of
the tail for the dime
or for the penny plus
the probability that I
have for the dime and then
times something like this, too.
And in a case like
this, where I'm summing
over all of the possibilities.
So in this case,
I'm either going
to get a head for the dime
or a tail for the dime.
It's not going to
balance on its end.
I'm assuming that
that chance is 0.
Then these two things
just add up to 1.
Is that all right?
It's really saying the
probability of the dime
will do something if I
have a head for the penny.
Is this all right?
So you want to practice doing
little algebra things like this
to make sure you
know how to do it.
Yes?
No?
Maybe?
Let's see what
else I've got here.
AUDIENCE: Professor.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yes
AUDIENCE: What you
just wrote, [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yeah,
what's the correct thing
to write in here?
What is the right thing?
AUDIENCE: Tails.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Yeah.
So it's tricky.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The
probability [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR:
Yeah, it's the easy way
to do it, for this case.
And so there's, like, a lot of--
for some cases, it might be
easier to write it this way.
In some cases,
write it that way.
It depends on how many
different options there are.
So anyway, I'm just trying to
warn you by writing this out.
It's like, you might
write down stuff quickly
without thinking about it.
And it's easy to double count.
Like for example, if you
put the other term in here,
you double count.
Because you already
have, they had head,
you already had
the head case here.
Yeah, maybe-- Did I write the--
I'll just write the base
theorem down the way you usually
see it.
So this is the
general expression,
which is always true.
The base theorem way to write it
is the probability of A given B
is equal to the probability of
B given A times the probability
of A over the probability of B.
And that's just
rearranging this equality.
Rearrange again.
And we'll come back to
this with the situation
that's like, what's the
probability that Professor
Green is 5' 9", given
our measurements,
is related to the probability
that if Professor Green was 5'
9", we would have made
the measurements we got.
So this is like that way
to invert that statement.
And if the thing that's
here is exclusive,
it means there's, like,
many possible things that
could happen.
This is the probability
that one of them happened.
There's a lot of other things
that could have happened.
For instance, like heads
and tails, it's either heads
or it's tails.
It's exclusive.
If it's like that, you could
rewrite that probability of B
is equal to probability of
Aj, probability of B given Aj
summed over j.
This is something,
whatever A measurement
it is, if it ends up with
B, that's probability B.
Is that all right?
So you can put that into
the denominator here.
You can substitute
that in so you
can rewrite this as
probability of Ai
given B is equal to the
probability of B given Ai
times the probability
of Ai divided
by the sum of the probability
of Aj [INAUDIBLE] Aj.
And this is the form that
you'll normally see based here.
A lot of times, we have a
continuous variable instead
of discrete events like this.
And so then we talk about
probability distributions.
And so instead of
having a sum there,
we might have an integral.
And this is a topic that also is
quite confusing to many people.
So suppose I had a
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
And I have, like, the
probability density
of having a certain velocity
in the extraction instead
of the particle.
And so that's going
to be something like e
to the negative 1/2 mvx squared
over keT divided by something.
And maybe it actually
is [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm not sure.
Maybe there's a vx here.
Something like that.
So you have an
expression that you
get for [INAUDIBLE] for
probability density.
Now, what does this mean?
We want this thing
to be the integral
of P of vx dvx over from
negative infinity to infinity.
We want this to equal something.
What do we want this to equal?
1.
So that means that the
units of this, this
is units of
centimeters per second,
what's the units of this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR: Centimeters
per second now minus 1.
It's, like, it's
per the unit to this
to get a dimensionless
number there.
So this has units of
seconds per centimeter,
which probably none of you
thought until I just said that
to you.
So probability
densities are tricky,
and they always have to
be multiplied by a delta.
When I talk about
this, I really need
to talk about P of vx, delta vx.
I need to have something
here to make this look
like a probability again.
And so the issue is
that the probability
that the velocity is exactly
something is, like, 0.
It's really the
probability that's
in a certain range,
plus or minus something.
Then you get a
nonzero probability.
There's another
quantity you'll see
a lot called the cumulative
probability distribution.
Let's see, what letter do I use?
Call it F. And this would
be like the integral
from negative infinity to
vx prime, or vx of P over vx
prime, dvx prime.
And this is the probability
that the particle
has vx less than something.
So this is F is equal to
the probability that vx--
let's call this vx star--
vx is less than or
equal to vx star.
And that can be quite
an important property.
So for example, you're
designing a supersonic nozzle.
You want to know what
gas molecules are going
to come out at a certain speed.
You really need to
know that probability.
How many of them are going to
be bigger than that speed, how
many less than that speed?
So these are two different ways
to express a similar thing.
This is, like, the
probably that it
does have that speed
within a certain range.
This is the probability that
it has anything less than
or equal to that speed.
And in a completely different
way, this is an integral.
This has units of dimensionless.
This has units of per velocity.
All right?
All right, we'll pick up
more of this on Monday.